[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to our
channel
today's episode is going to be about
self-discipline which is a quality of
successful people
[Music]
and we're going to elaborate this matter
in a student's perspective
thank you for watching
if you like our content
make sure to subscribe to our channel
and share this with everyone
self-discipline is known as a quality of
successful people
but how does that work
what do we mean by a quality of
successful people how do we build
self-discipline
this and everything else will be tackled
in today's episode
self-discipline refers to the ability to
control how you respond to your emotions
and push yourself to achieve your
greatest aspirations they say
this is a fundamental skill associated
with success in life it's often compared
to maturity or intelligence and age
whereas many people or many adults
practice poor self-discipline and
self-control
which sometimes leads to an endless
depressing cycle of being stuck in
mediocrity and doing nothing to betters
and doing nothing to better one's own
life long term
it can also heavily influence a person's
social and economic status
discipline varies in people
take gamblers as an example
due to going through emotional
situations
through wins and losses discipline
especially self-control has been lost
due to addiction
there are many ways through which we can
learn to be more disciplined be in more
control of our own actions have more
control over ourselves
a good example of self-discipline are
hard-working students
they are able to control their own
time
they're able to set boundaries to manage
the time as well as possible
and
meditation also plays a big role in this
it is a good way in how we can channel
our emotions our energy turn it into
something positive
furthermore we can also move closer to a
more disciplined life through setting
goals or having
daily goals or monthly goals
goals also provide you
with a clear picture of what you need to
accomplish
another common practice is to always set
deadlines for your objectives
this acts as a motivator and encourages
you to work hard this will also help you
to establish a better work life balance
and feel more in control over the flow
of your life day-to-day
setting both short and long-term goals
as well as a well-thought-out plan to
reach them is a smart idea and it's a
very good start when it comes to
building your self-discipline
it is the driving force that helps to
catapult individuals out of the
mediocrity and into better lives for
themselves and their loved ones
it doesn't have to strictly apply to
academics or career growth either it can
also apply to social and relationship
development as well as one's health
for example when looking to get into
better shape many give up or don't even
start because they fear it may be too
difficult or drastic of a change to
strive for
those with strong self-discipline as
well as encouragement for their friends
and family tend to have much more
success in doing this but most of them
don't
they'll be more likely to stick to a
diet instead of cheating and to
establish a workout schedule to better
themselves physically and the result is
that these people end up living happier
healthier day after day and end up also
living more confidently
this also gives the feeling that they
have control over themselves their mind
their bodies and their lives
as touched on briefly self-discipline
ties in heavily with
self-control which in itself it's not
just a form of control
the reason why so many people struggle
with self-discipline is that we live in
a society where people are gradually
losing the ability to think for
themselves
and make their own informed decisions
this is something that ties in with the
world of technology as well
let's take our social media for example
those have definitely a
those have a bad influence on our
uh process of building a self-esteem and
also building uh the self-discipline
that we are
trying to achieve as one of our
monthly or yearly goals
we have grown accustomed to relying on
lock down walled garden products and
services that are designed to limit the
control of the consumer
or to reduce the amount of decisions
consumers have to make for themselves
in a nutshell indoctrinating the next
generation to simply do as they're told
and not look into things not think them
through or
have a critical thinking process on
deciding something
uh whether it's something you want to
buy in in a
in a shop or
whether it's something you want to buy a
new cell phone a new product whatever
that
advertisements are showing up in your on
your screen
not having to think for themselves and
make their own decisions is actually
something that many people find
a sense of comfort in
they're content with mediocrity they
don't see a reason for anything to
change because in their eyes it's uh
good enough
this is also very similar to how many
former prisoners believe
that they found a sense of comfort in
not having to make their own decisions
or make their own money or make their
own life work again
albeit not a great situation to be in
they were
i mean a lot of prisoners were
guaranteed a living space and three
meals a day
as a society over time we have
sacrificed a rapidly increasing number
of our freedoms and our control over our
own lives for convenience and this sense
of stability
um
finally in my opinion
when we are self-disciplined we are also
very proactive in making the decisions
that will ultimately benefit us in the
long term the common expression lazy
people work twice as hard
is more factual than many may realize
those who are content with mediocrity
and do not push themselves to break out
a little harder
tend to stay there the longest it is
only when we as people begin to take
control of our own lives
our own habits our own thoughts and our
own small acts of kindness that we begin
to find success
and the good things in life will not
just come to you they say that the
pieces are already there for you and
it's up to you
and it's up to us
to find them and put them together
and uh this is all for today
if you really like this episode make
sure to check out our channel for other
similar episodes about very interesting
topics
and to subscribe to our channel
thank you for listening
[Music]
you